the Bible part two  frankly I love the Bible the Bible is my  favorite book it's my favorite book next  to out of the deal that's my second  favorite book people ask me about the  Bible which test I like both Testaments  I read so many Testaments people they  call me the Testament reading machine  without many Testaments I read my only  problem if Trump is the way the truth  and the light the only difference I  would have never been crucified I think  Christ put himself in a bad position  horrible position to be crucified why  because of the Pharisees and the  Sadducees frankly the Fabri sees they  would have taken by course the Sadducees  would have taken my calls we'd have a  deal they said let's now they say he's  crucified I crucified the guy because of  because of Christ the expression was for  him I would have never put myself in  that position if Trump is the way to  salvation frankly you'd take my call  look here - you'll be answer more of  your questions about the Bible